Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to play some more with OpenAI’s
amazing technique DALL-E 2, where we can write
a text description, and the AI creates an
amazing image of exactly that. That sounds cool,
and it gets even cooler the
crazier the ideas we give to it.
This is an AI endowed with a diffusion-based
model, which means that when we ask it something,
it starts out from noise, and over
time, it iteratively refines this image
to match our description better. And, over
time, magically, an absolutely incredible image
emerges. This is a neural network that is given
a ton of images, and a piece of text description
that says what is in this image. That
is one image-caption pair. DALL-E 2
is given millions and millions of these pairs.
So, what can it do with all this knowledge?
Well, the best part is that it can combine
things! Oh yes, this is the key. This does
not copy images from this training data, but
it truly comes up with novel images. How?
Well, after it had seen a
bunch of images of koalas,
and separately, a bunch of images of motorcycles,
it starts to understand the concept of both,
and it will be able to combine the two
together into a completely new image.
And here you can see how much DALL-E
2 has improved since DALL-E 1. It is
on a completely different
level from its first iteration.
This is so much better, and once again,
this is an AI that was improved this much
in just a year? I can hardly believe what
I am seeing here. What a time to be alive!
And now that some time has passed, new,
interesting capabilities have emerged.
Now, hold on to your papers, and let’s
have a look at 10 more amazing examples.
One, for instance, it can even create not
just images, but small videos. Videos?
How? Well, look at this video where a victorian
house is getting modernized! Wow. So what is going
on here? Well, we can enter a text prompt, get an
image, then change the text just a tiny bit, get a
slightly changed image, and repeat the process
over and over until we get an amazing video
like this. We can also run this process backwards
and victorianize a modern building as well.
Two, if you don’t believe that it can
combine several existing concepts into
something that definitely does not exist, hold
on to your papers, and have a look at this one.
Oh yes, Apple products, Leonardo Da Vinci style.
This is truly insane. If all this does not feel
like humanlike intelligence, I don’t know what is.
Three, here is how the AI imagines
a robot learning a new language.
Four, it can create new kinds of drinks, and,
my goodness. Well, I am super happy now. You are
probably asking, Károly, why are you super happy?
Well, I am a light transport researcher by trade,
and I spend a great deal of my time computing
caustics. Oh yes, caustics are these beautiful
patterns that emerge when we hit a reflective
or refractive object with light just the right
way. And these can look especially magical
if we have an object with a complex geometry.
And the fact that the AI also understands this
about our world. I am truly speechless. Beautiful.
Five, it can also create new
inventions. This is a toilet car.
You know, some people are quite busy and
if you have to go when you are on the go,
well, this one is for you.
What a time to be alive!
Six, in this one, the AI puts up a clinic in
understanding combinations of concepts. Check
this out! This is plants surrounding a lightbulb.
Now, a lightbulb surrounding some plants.
Now a plant with a lightbulb inside.
And a lightbulb with plants inside.
It can follow these instructions
really well an all of these cases.
Seven, it can also create larger images too, so
much so, that entire murals can be requested.
And here, not just the quality, but the
variety of results is truly a sight to behold.
Eight, this is the famous Sith Lord, Darth Ant.
Oh yes. This is Darth Vader
reimagined as a robot ant. Loving it.
Nine, if you remember, previously, when we
requested that it writes a piece of text on
a sign, it floundered a great deal. This
sign is supposed to say “deep learning”.
And, look! The amazing Peter Welinder found
a way to make it write things on signs
properly. And all this with an amazing depth of
field effect. Once again, this is an AI where a
vast body of knowledge lies within, but it only
emerges if we can bring it out with properly
written prompts. It almost feels like a new
kind of programming that is open to everyone,
even people without any programming or
technical knowledge. This is prompt engineering,
if you will. Perhaps a new kind of job
that is just coming into existence.
Ten, now check this out. We can even give
instructions to it as a photographer would
instruct its camera, request mammatus clouds, we
marveled together at a simulation of those in an
earlier video. And, oh my goodness. That cannot
be true. Look. The hand has subsurface scattering.
What is that? That is the effect
of light penetrating the skin,
bouncing around, and either coming out on the
same, or the other side. It has this absolutely
beautiful halo effect. We worked on this a bit
in an earlier paper together with Activision
Blizzard, and it took a great deal of mathematics
and physics to perform this efficiently in a
computer graphics engine. And now, the AI just
knows what it is. I really don’t know what to say.
And, as always, +1 because I couldn’t resist:
if you are interested in trying a reduced
version of DALL-E, check this out. The link is
available in the video description. Once again,
please note that this is a
highly reduced version of DALL-E,
but it is still quite fun.
Let the experiments begin!
And, I also cannot wait to get access to the full
model, some Two Minute Papers mascot figures, and
obviously, images of wise scholars holding on
to their papers must to come into existence!
I am sure this tool will democratize art
creation by putting it into the hands of all
of us. We all have so many ideas and so little
time. And DALL-E will help with exactly that.
So cool. Just imagine having an AI artist that is,
let’s say, just half as good as a human artist,
but the AI can paint 10000 images a day for
free. Cover art for your album? Illustrations
for your novel? Not a problem. A little brain in
a jar for everyone, if you will. And, now, it’s
a really good one. Bravo OpenAI. I am starting to
believe that the impact of this AI is going to be
so strong, there will be the world as we know
it before DALL-E, and the world after it. So,
does this get your mind going? What else would you
use this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!